just I'm sorry the 200 000 like that's  crazy to me that's like  oh my gosh I cannot believe that's crazy  someone that can make that amount of  money in a shorter period of time like  somebody who would say a musical artist  right  somebody who's in entertainment somebody  who's on a TV show somebody who does  like concerts and tours that amount of  money isn't the same to them you know  what I mean  what do you mean like say I was dating  somebody like a pretty easy right okay  he makes 150 000 minimum per show  minimum that's what he makes it a show  yeah so if he does a couple shows the  200 Grand to him he won't even feel it  no but like this is something coming  from someone like I've been in a  relationship with a guy that was worth  over a million  like I but I would never in a million  years ask him to spend 200k on a ring